Graham I want to start with you because
you're the person who has been involved
with this film the longest how long has
it been for you to get this made and get
all of the rights and what would you say
were some of the biggest obstacles in
getting to tonight you guys I never
spare four hours it's been close to a
decade close to ten years that I first
met with Miami Beach Brian May and Roger
Taylor and we started discussing how to
make a film with their lives and a
celebration of Freddie's life with the
music so as you guys know nearly all of
you know it takes so long when you're
working on people's life stories to
carve out a 2 hour 2 hour and 20 minute
film that we had so many versions of the
script and going back and forth and you
know you get one shot at this and and
you got to get it right and I think we
did get it right yeah I really do Rami
do you remember when the idea was first
floated for you to play Freddie Mercury
was it someone else coming to you and
saying we think you'd be good for this
was it or was it you you know I was just
trying to figure out what the day was
yesterday cuz it's all come full circle
but somewhere and I think in the spring
of 2016
I met with Graham in his office and we
hung out for about six hours and I was
wondering why you think you know he
thought I would be right for Freddie
Mercury and he and Dennis O'Sullivan and
watched mr. robot which is a show about
a a thank you a profoundly alienated
human being with social anxiety that has
trouble stepping out and from his
monitor and the kind of the antithesis
to Freddie Mercury so I was kind of
shocked about this and I told them
listen man I don't sing I don't play the
piano
my body articulates itself in a in a
unusual way I would say and that's maybe
the closest thing I am to Freddie but I
don't know somehow I have to think of me
Dave
he and Dennis had some foresight in
putting this all together so how did you
come around to the idea how did I come
around to it I think at that point I
just said yes absolutely and and I
walked out the door and then I went home
and I thought what have I done you know
you start immediately I started watching
footage of him all the archival footage
and I said well there's a reason they're
making a movie but there's also a reason
that only one person could do that and
it seemed like an impossible task
except I said listen you got one shot at
doing something living out your dream
someone offers you this and you have to
do it I thought about every other actor
who has as much talent and doesn't get
afforded these opportunities and you
just can't you can't let yourself down
you can't let anybody else down and I
thought hey it's a big risk but what's
life about and the spirit of Freddie you
take a little risk and see how it goes
Rami and Joe I can only imagine like the
YouTube wormholes you must have gone
down just to study you know how Freddie
carried himself on stage how John Deacon
moved with the bass guitar were you guys
looking for stuff that was just about
your individual person you know video
clips or were you finding stuff and
sending it to each other like oh yeah I
just found this you should watch this
yeah well I mean specifically live a it
I think there's like like 10 million
views of that on YouTube I think we're 5
million of them yeah it's fun well you
know it's sort of funny because it's
it's obviously when you go to youtube
and you watch that concert footage it's
like mostly Freddie right he's the
frontman he's the guy but that's what's
so great about actually being able to
make this movie in the age of the
Internet in the age of YouTube because
you can like go to concerts like famous
concerts they did and they have like the
John Deakin camera where you just follow
John Deakin for three hours and see what
he does for every single song some of
its not that interesting but you still
get to see all of it and so stuff like
that was like really important for for
me to China try to just kind of get down
all this movements and everything he
does when it came to the accent it was
sort of the opposite where I actually
tried to find interviews where only he
was talking because I didn't want to get
distracted by the other accents John's
accident something I'd never even heard
before like this East Midlands English
accent but I think only he has I don't
know but uh I found it and and so yeah I
would actually try to to kind of put
blinders on in that sense and then I
would just like every morning before we
would shoot like in my trailer I would
just watch like a 10-minute interview
with him just to get myself in the voice
and get ourselves kind of going that way
and then for you around me were you
wanting to see stuff clips from Freddie
on stage and obviously off I mean did
you find that one was more illuminating
than the other if if I ever found myself
in some rabbit hole of trying to
discover who he was I would just put on
you something he did on stage just to
get that excitement about everything
re-energized to a certain degree I would
I would allocate certain time for for
each thing I found obviously I think
I've scoured through every performance
he's ever done I mean if there was a guy
recording it in Japan in 1980 and you
know for just his own home video usage I
saw it and I would you know I exhausted
everything I could find I started
listening to radio interviews and
finally when I got through all of that I
said well you know even a radio
interview you can you can hear him
sometimes ask for a vodka tonic or
or a cup of tea and you see this a
gentle side of him that's yes he can
sometimes be very aggressive he can
lower his register he can sometimes be
you know very eloquent and and humble
and kind and generous and his register
goes up a little bit but the thing that
helped me the most in terms of
identifying who he was privately was was
something of a diary in all of his music
and I would just I went to all of his
lyrics I thought he's writing everything
straight from his heart straight from
his soul so I've started writing
everything out and you know compiled
what I thought was you know a story of
his life and and the things that he was
extremely passionate about a thing that
things that he was longing for and you
see a few themes running through which
are loneliness and the search for love
and trying to fill a certain void Lucy
I'm so fascinated by the relationship as
portrayed in the film between Mary and
Freddy particularly the scene where he's
coming out to you as bisexual and you
say no Freddy you're gay what intrigued
you the most about what you learned
about the two of them together and and
Mary and specifically I think it is that
kind of undefinable nature of the
relationship that has kind of infuriated
a lot of people in the way I've found
during the research that a lot of
Freddy's fans are very opinionated about
that relationship and I think it is that
undefinable quality to it that's quite
provocative that it doesn't fit into the
kind of genre or category of
relationship that were very that people
are more used to seeing at that time and
I think in a way that's what led to its
success in a way or at least was the
vehicle for its the longevity of that
relationship and it was just a
fascinating thing to explore I'm Brian
May was my main source of all things
Freddy and Mary he was actually the
person who introduced them
so to get his point of view kind of his
outside point of view off the trajectory
of their relationship starting from when
they first met and had this kind of
clarity of sight with one another that
so few were granted and so few got and
it was that clarity and that deep love
and respect that they found seemingly
very early on that was then able to
drive them and carry them throughout the
kind of unpredictable trajectory of
their relationship and allow them to be
more I suppose pragmatic and open-minded
and open-hearted whatever came to it was
just that very solid foundation and in
that kind of unconventional way was
really really beautiful and kind of all
shades of things to explore Alan your
portrayal Paul has such charm and a
fabulous mustache but yet at the same
time you really do get the sense that
he's not a soul mate along the lines of
Mary or II or Jim Hutton what were you
trying to get across with your
performance and the relationship the
thing that struck me about pose the
relationship between Paul and Freddie
they were both quite lonely people and I
think that was the common factor that
brought them together they were both at
the time closeted in their sexuality
when they first met and through that
kind of common ground
Paul gained a trust he gained Freddie's
trust and with that trust came a lot of
power and it was what Paul did with that
power that made him such a malevolent
force and such a diverse the divisive
force within in Freddie's life and in
the in the band's life as well Romney
what was it that you think helped you
the most in kind of a magical way when
you put it on for me I do this I think
because of you know the collective
effort that we all put together and you
know communally come together and
collaborate in a way that is for me
that's the magic of it all from you know
you can talk about all the aesthetics as
well but you can talk about
our cinematographer was divine Tom
Siebel is incredible
I had a producer that is the best in the
business and you know in all regard in
all regards I mean he before the film
was even financed I had a studio behind
that I asked him for a few things asked
him for a dialect coach I said I was
gonna go to London and and get things
with the ball rolling and he you know he
gave me the opportunity to get a piano
teacher as a singing teacher all the
help I needed a choreographer and I
realized oh I don't need a choreographer
I need a movement coach and I had I had
watched I loved Eddie redmayne's
performance in the theory of everything
and I said who's he working with and
apparently he's still working with this
person so I couldn't have them so I had
to find my own her name was pauly Bennet
and she ended up working with the entire
band throughout but you know we would
sit in a studio in London a dance studio
and ballet studio and she got me to a
point where I had to buy a pair of
tights and walk around with this half
mic for about six months yeah and we
would go into the studio sometimes we
would work on just little hand gestures
sometimes we would watch Liza Minnelli
because Freddie was such a fan of hers
and to stole a lot of her moves it was
even it was more influential to watch
Liza sometimes than it was to watch
Freddie watch Bob Fosse and at times she
would you know she was she would have me
do Killer Queen as a soliloquy in the
style of Marie Antoinette and I would
you know I'd say well alright
she keeps Moishe and on and then with a
British accent and all the sudden things
were happening to my body I was like oh
is she's good she's good I rendered her
paycheck and then Jan Sewell was my
makeup artist someone that Graham and
worked with in the past and I'm gonna
try to take her everywhere I go you know
she's not yes she did so many things I
don't want to reveal all the secrets but
she she got my eyes I think at times not
as to look isn't as big as they kind of
can be in other projects but they are in
this at times and then Julian day was
incredible with with costumes as well I
would use all the time with Jan in
makeup and go into Julie and and do all
of the costume fittings and then use
that as rehearsal time I said this is
exactly what Freddie would be doing he'd
be trying on everything seeing what
really worked what would what would it
play well on stage and it was some of
the best use of my time I think but it
was a collective effort I would not be
here without every single one of those
people that had a hand in this I think
because of the story we were telling it
it raised everybody's game and I would
definitely not be here without this cast
day in and day out I think they knew the
immense weight on my shoulders and they
lifted me up and I hope I can say the
same with with what I I was able to
offer for them but really this is it was
an incredible top-notch as good as it
gets cast to work with thank you so much
for being here